the day that it's clear on the night
that it's clear that Trump's been
re-elected heads will be exploding on
the Harvard campus the Stanford campus
the Yale campus the New York Times
officers CNN will be in meltdown
everybody will be on air in tears
predicting the end of the Republic all
that stuff will be going on and the
market will be rallying because
investors will know that this will
represent an improvement just as it was
an improvement when Trump got elected I
mean the Trump Administration got no
claudits for this because the media
refused to acknowledge it but in fact
the deregulation and the tax cuts
delivered significant improvements the
labor market was in great shape for the
first time since 1999 real household
disposable income went up it had
flatlined since the Clinton years and
Trump delivered a nine percent increase
in real disposable household income now
people have got short memories in
America but they're not that short and
people aren't so suffering from Amnesia
that they've forgotten how well things
were going until the pandemics dropped